quarterback uh patrick mahomes is one of
two texas tech players to be drafted in
the top 10
in the super bowl era and obviously
patrick mahomes did the virtual
commencement address for texas tech
this weekend who is the other texas tech
player to be taken in the top
10 of the draft in the super bowl era
chris
you know this what say that again hold
on one more time i was not ready for the
question i was reading something on our
document
okay patrick moms
hopefully the audience wasn't listening
the first time either patrick mahomes is
one of two texas tech players to be
drafted in the top 10 in the super bowl
era who
is the other oh sorry about that that
would be michael crabtree
am i correct with that yeah it should
count as an incorrect though i should
have forced you to answer it at the time
because
i didn't hear the question would not
have been the correct answer to the
question
you know when you started talking about
the mahomes commencement speech
i kind of just went off and didn't
listen to you for a second just to make
sure i was at the right place in our
sheets here to pay attention to where we
are in the show
and i didn't think you were reading the
question so sorry my bad but i got it
right
so i get the first pick i mean
all right i want to see bill belichick
i'm sorry i mean like
it's kind of like but but bill belichick
for two reasons i'd want to see bill
belichick as my commencement speaker
one he can be a little uncomfortable
speaking publicly
which i think would be entertaining to
watch where you'd go man here's a guy
that can get in front of
53 grown man tough football players
and yell at them and you know make jokes
or be
serious and whatever it may be and
command that room like no other
but then yet get in front of some school
kids and be a little bit
like not in his zone and a little
uncomfortable that way
and then also i think he's going to shed
some great advice and knowledge on you
that's where i think i'd want to listen
to bill belichick i mean he's going to
teach you
or have a few things as far as approach
work ethic
you know just deep thoughts that i think
would help any young kid out so that's
why belichick would be my first pick
see i i was inclined to go belichick
not for any of the reasons you said i
have a very very basic
rule of thumb when it comes to
commencements and i've been there i've
done that i've sat there
and what do you typically do when you
attend a commencement right
you have the program and you just like i
know at least what i do
okay what's next what's next what's next
what's next let's just get this damn
thing over with and i think bill
belichick's
speech would be short enough that it
would
move the program along because really
who remembers anything
that they ever heard at any commencement
that ever was performed in the history
of the world
does anybody remember anything i mean
maybe if like the fan man guy
showed up remember the guy that used to
crash events in the parachute yeah right
yeah maybe something like that you would
remember and and and you know what the
most memorable speech would be the one
where the person just says
thank you and good night and walks away
so yeah right
you know i don't know i i tend to think
that bill belichick would not have a
long speech so i would want belichick
for that reason
all right i i'm gonna go um
there's a lot i can choose from mike
ditka was a name that popped up to me
though
and i know he's currently not in the nfl
and we've been talking about the 85
bears
a lot lately we had him in the draft
last week but
when you think about presence when you
think about somebody who is going to
give you the kind of advice that he
knows you need even if you don't want to
hear it
it's going to be mike ditka he's going
to have a cigar right
and he's going to tell you what you need
to know and it may not be pleasant it
may not be comfortable
and it may not be short but within that
there are going to be some very useful
nuggets if you just bother to listen to
what this guy is
saying because he will coach you into
the spot where you need to be
so forget about all i said with bill
belichick being short and sweet if i'm
going to sit and listen to somebody i
want to listen to mike ditka
guy i'm not mad at you there he's on my
list he'd be one of those guys that
yeah it's going to be knowledge say some
funny things
certainly and go off the rails a little
bit so that's good
but you know all right so i made it like
a serious first pick
here's a little bit of a different angle
i'm going terry bradshaw i'm going
similar
with you terry bradshaw you know you
said you might learn some things with
belichick or dick
you probably won't learn anything with
terry bradshaw but you will have
a great laugh that's what i can count on
with terry bradshaw he will go
off the rails he is a great storyteller
he's one of the greatest personalities
i've ever been around i mean i can't
tell you
how many times i've laughed with terry
bradshaw so yeah it might not be like
lifelong knowledge but if you want to
remember a good commencement speech and
have a laugh and say oh that was
enjoyable i think terry bradshaw would
be your guy
i'm going to stay in pittsburgh as well
on this one and i'm influenced by recent
events i want james harrison up there
first of all
i want to hear more about what was in
the envelope and second of all i mean
when you talk about a presence
and somebody's going to tell you
something you need to hear and you
better listen
it's james harrison so give me james
harrison round two
yeah okay it's funny because actually i
was actually thinking about
maybe going mike tomlin with this
conversation
uh but i'm gonna go back he could tell
us what was in the envelope he could
also tell us what was in the envelope
well who cares i mean why we're on that
who cares no
okay we don't have time i know okay fine
for p-f-t-o-t we don't have time
okay i'll save it for that all right i'm
gonna go with pete carroll i want to see
pete carroll chewing his gum and i'm i'm
not
and moving around and dancing around the
podium and and
of course pete carroll hey he's been
successful in so many different places
he's got great energy about him
i mean yeah he walks around like he's 79
years old but then you get him on a
football field with a piece of gum and
he jumps around like he's 27 years old
so i i i would love to be sitting in a
seat listen to his motivational tactics
his energy things like that
uh last one for me and i'm torn here i'm
torn between david baker
and chris berman uh i'll go chris berman
even though the commencement will never
end pack a lunch pack a dinner
bring a sleeping bag once he gets that
microphone folks he is not giving it up
but every
a second of it will be entertaining
he'll have a nickname for everyone in
the class
uh i'll i'll take chris berman
reluctantly uh
and uh i almost went john madden i hear
you there i almost went john madden
which i should have i just wasn't sure
you know where john nods out as a
speaker right now
being you know up there in years a
little bit
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports